Yo, what's up? its Yoroomie and I'm back. In my first video
I talked to you about how I took studio time from an idea to building the MVP in an evening
Launching it, which generated over a million hits to the site, the first ten thousand dollars in revenue literally in weeks. So in this video
I want to talk to you a little bit more and what I got a lot of questions about which was how do you take
this initial marketplace MVP and scale it into being the largest online community music studios in the entire world which it is today and
What tools did you use to help you do that?
I'm gonna talk in this video about all those tools, and how I use them together to run studio time
And I also want to mention one thing, and that's a lot of people think that studio time is a large venture-backed
startup with the big team behind it and a lot of capital which equates
resources. The answer is that it's not. It's actually just me right now
and I can effectively run studio time pretty much from my phone on the go no matter
You know, what I'm doing or where I am. So now that you know that it is just me
I want to talk to you about these tools that I use that help me to do that. Some of these tools
You've probably heard of. They are WordPress
Sharetribe
Zapier
Chargebee
Stripe and Slack. I'm gonna talk to you more about how I effectively use these tools together and
leverage the tech technology as much as possible
So I didn't have to really build anything custom for studio time. So first off, a lot of people also are wondering and have
commented on my other video and that is, this studio time built on Sharetribe's open source or
hosted version? So there's two different versions of Sharetribe available
I'll link down here to both of them below, so you can check them out yourself, but in short
viewer time is actually on Sharetribe's hosted platform
Now I could go into the extensive detail talking about this, but to keep it very brief
I simply and in doing so that way I can leverage
Sharetribe is mainly for the hosting and support of studio time
Anything goes wrong or if there's anything that you know needs to be done on the platform
Then I can simply contact Sharetribe and they can take care of that since I'm paying them for their hosted platform
So marketplace solution. Now, I did have to modify
Sharetribe to platform to of course to meet my needs for studio time and provide for a very customized user
experience on the site. Now
the easy way to see how I use
Sharetribe and then WordPress
together that way it creates more of a customized experience for users
It's just simply look at the domains in your browser when you go to
www.studiotime.io
Which is the home page. You will see that that is a very custom look
That is not on other Sharetribe marketplaces. Now, the reason why is that
www.studiotime.io
and anything that is on that domain for instance the /y
/subscription or the community of artists, producers and engineers and others is actually on
Wordpress.So I built custom WordPress pages that I could easily
modify through this kind of template that I created and I simply used different domains and
You'll notice the subdomains. Those are
www.studiotime.io as I mentioned, but Sharetribes is actually listing stopstudiotime.io
So the different functionality that is on Sharetribe is actually any of the user accounts of account
creation goes into the listing creation for studio listings
Which then goes into requesting studios from user to listing then the messaging
then the payments and then also the reviews. That is all done on Sharetribes posted platform
And that is the functionality that Sharetribe is capable of. But for the user to come to studiotime.io
there needed to be a little bit more than that and improve user experience
thus that's why I use
WordPress in conjunction with Sharetribe. Now that you know a little bit more about that
I'm going to talk about how I actually collect subscription payments and manage that process
with that not technically being possible on Sharetribe alone. When you click on a or go to the subscription
www.
studiotime.io/
subscription
Then you'll notice that it's also on that WordPress page
So there's a few different pricing options for these
subscription
packages that we require to list your studio on studiotime. And when you select one of those you'll notice that domain is then different
then studiotime.io
And also the listings.studiotime.io. That is because I actually used Chargebee which is a great
solution for
subscriptions and subscription management
You will notice on that they take care of the hosting on that and then also when someone selects many subscriptions
they are having the
They can manage it through their kind of charge via account that is not like a you know
It's not it's not a big ask for someone to create an account with that. It's simple
You know the name that the kind of password
Generation which can be the same as the other accounts so it's really not been a big deal so far
I can leverage chargbee be effectively on the studio time marketplace, and it really doesn't disrupt user experience also
Something to mention is Chargebee integrates with Stripe
So stripe is the payment gateway that we use for collecting the subscriptions. With the subscribptions
Not only do we use Chargebee for subscription. You know sign up management
They also have a pretty cool dashboard, so I can see all the different KPIs (key performance
indicators) associated with subscriptions. Such as, monthly recurring revenue, annual recurring revenue, churn all these other kind of
Pretty cool KPIs and analytics I can see through Chargebee's dashboard
Which I have since I used their platform. Also on Stripe's side, I can issue any charge backs
refunds any of that I can do through Stripe, which is of course, the payment gateway
So now you know how I use Sharetribe, WordPress,
ChargeBee and Stripe. I'm gonna
talk a little bit more about how I effectively run this marketplace
And leverage these different technologies together in one. Now, I do that by using Slack
You've probably heard and probably also use Slack with larger teams or other team members
But since I run studiotime myself, I actually have my own team funny enough in
Slack, but I use it for different channels to create and send myself different notifications for different events that are happening
real-time in studiotime
So for instance, in the social channel I get a notification that it's being mentioned on social so I can timely
reply and also interact with people on the social channels. For instance, any signups new
subscriptions I get a notification in Slack for new subscriptions
So I get that chaching and then I see that we got paid in a new subscription
And who that is and I can actually then automate an email to them making sure that they get their studio listings set up
On the site. I also have created a web code with that using
Zapier in which is another tool to then
notify myself and send myself a notification in Slack that if this new subscriber did not create a
New listing within a certain amount of time I can send a notification so that way it can reach
And send the second email to them and make sure that they can get their studio set up and don't have any problems with that
That just really increases and enhances the user and customer experience on studiotime
So there's a few other notifications that I send myself through Slack. In a quick summary
Slack just allows me to integrate multiple platforms and in different different technology solutions into one
Since I don't have a custom kind of back-end, and you know API integrations
I use Slack as that main integration point then I also use Zapier as I mentioned to crate the semi self web hooks
For different notifications that I need to be able to run studiotime on the go from my phone
No matter where I am or what I'm doing
So hopefully this gives you a pretty good idea of how I've taken studiotime from the initial
MVP to being the largest online community of music studios in the entire world and
Believe it or not not using a custom built
Platform but simply leveraging a lot of different platforms and technology solutions out there for very individual
Functionality and different things that I need and hopefully you can get a good idea of how you can then use these tools
For your side project or your startup. Hit subscribe so I can keep making these videos and also
Comment below with any questions you have. I try to reply to every comment
Comment below and let me know what you want to hear about or any questions you have about taking your marketplace
MVP to scale and different tools and different technology platforms, you can leverage to do so thanks